découpe des prix une quarantaine de
récompenses gagnées au fil des années
par le club d'échecs de la dame noire
depuis 1988 il s'est imposé comme un
incontournable à montigny le bretonneux
au départ il n'y avait pas de club à
montigny et puis donc c'est des gens qui
étaient au club du chenet qui ont ont
décidé de créer un nouveau club à
montigny c'est un club à ces actifs ont
fait différents tournois et on joue tous
les tous les vendredis soir et on donne
des cours le samedi après midi
parmi les tournois celui d'automne
pendant les vacances de la toussaint un
tournoi de neuf rondes avec une partie
par jour un rythme soutenu qui s'adresse
avant tout à des initiés c'est un jeu
qui est très exigeant donc il faut je
pense d'abord se préparer un peu
physiquement c'est à dire avoir une vie
relativement saine pour pouvoir aborder
dans de bonnes conditions des partis qui
sont quand même assez long commence à
14h elle termine au tour d'un 19 heures
il faut du sérieux faut arriver à être
un peu celui de c'est-à-dire à maîtriser
quelque part ses émotions quand
l'adversaire joue un ragoût qu'on
n'avait pas prévu aujourd'hui le club
compte une soixantaine d'adhérentes de 6
à 80 ans il recherche toujours des
candidats pour transmettre sa passion
des échecs
la 16e édition de ce tournoi d'automne
se déroulera du 21 au 29 octobre